wo bist du willst du das schlucken wir
sind da wir das ist ihr körper weniger
wind gewinnt
geil das ist dass es bei der weiter
wartete sogar dazu bereit ist zu sehen
ja aber erst das passwort passwort ja
was ist denn
egal kommentar ein punkt der das noch
mal an
logisches und herzlich willkommen zu
einer weiteren folge von minecraft
legend mit dem team
wer jetzt auf den server wir haben
gerade und im gegensatz zur letzten
folge noch mal kurz zeit genommen um auf
twitter ich packe hatte
damals einen rauszuhauen stellt uns doch
fragen
und da wären jetzt werden wir werden wir
natürlich raus aus der action sind ab
und zu mal ein paar fragen beantworten
es wäre ganz praktisch wenn du jetzt das
eisen mal holst dass wir brauchen für
das gold was überall ist dass wir das
mal mitnehmen reisen habe ich hier ganz
was ist aus dem ofen geworden also den
abgebauter vorne dann hab ich nicht
mitgenommen glaube ich dann steht da
noch was zu sagen und ich mir gedacht
hab ich wohl mal kurz das eisen hier
vorne aus dem anderen rufen denn nicht
der fall jetzt werden wir natürlich
nehmen das nehmen was mal noch so ein
bisschen kohle noch so ein bisschen
ich habe keinen job beim inventar für
eisen und
ja wenn ich mein ganzes inventar vorhin
in die kiste gepackt wo sonst doch nicht
alles was hat der stress sich gerade ein
bisschen
lack und ja also dann lass einfach mal
loslegen mit den toter fragen würde ja
also ich brauche ich erstmal kurz
unseren ofen auf oder wir davon haben
1000 davon am eingangstor besser wenn
man hier eine kleine base errichten the
base
case
handelskrieg jetzt noch mal ein bisschen
gold da ist noch eine riesige höhle luke
dadc weg
sind jetzt übrigens hat es sich schon
entdeckt diese riesig groß naja diese
ethisch große habe ich schon gesehen
aber ich muss gerade noch auf ein eisen
warten nicht aufgeholt sondern noch ein
eisen eigentlich weil ich mir noch eine
schöne spitzhacke machen will damit ich
auch mal das ganze zeug mitnehmen kann
dann las er nachher dieser folge auf
jeden fall auch diese hürde unten
erkunden das sollten wir auch noch
machen die frage finde ich ganz gut da
können wir ja mal anfangen herrschte
gloger über den könnt ihr über den
hashtag könnte übrigens fragen stellen
und zwar wie denkt ihr kommt ihr in
legend wie weit denkt hier kommt ihr in
legend eine ganz gute frage
jetzt nachdem wir so zwei folgen runter
haben uns zu sehen wie es bei uns gerade
läuft also ich denke wir sind eher
wahrscheinlich nicht so die aller kasten
den schnellsten was der kult mit angeht
aber wir können halt beide ganz gut so
weil games pvp haben wir ganz gut drin
und deswegen denke ich sollten
eigentlich schon relativ weit kommen
auch wenn jetzt aufs scoreboard schaut
sind wir zweitbestes team also ich denke
wir werden jetzt nicht dramatisch
verpacken so lange es kein grober fehler
unterläuft ja sollte es nicht gut laufen
dass man jetzt die große höhle ja
gleich
vorne am eingehen da wo wir vor hoch
gekommen sind das skelett das skelett
das
am eingang da wo wir auf dem strip mein
gang übergegangen sind da unten ich
mache ich sicher hier erstmal auch das
ist ja riskantes über lara ich muss mal
zwei eimer
wasser
ich bin in der hölle angekommen okay der
häuser lieber hier ist ein riesiger
kleine also ein kleiner lover sees hier
passt sich richtig auf gerade für mich
warum fliegt der einem inventar aus wenn
ich rechtsklick mache ich nehme einfach
ganz ohne das muss ich das muss ich eine
zeit dann auch nicht wusstest du dass
man seinen ofen mit nase halten kann ja
ja ultras viele brennern hatten
also
da kommt sorgen die mit ketten ich habe
ja auch gar kein problem brennt in der
lava ich werde dir etwas getrübt ist
verbrannt er hat was leute wir müssen ja
auch dringend beheizen ich hab' ich
brenne ich brenne ich brenne ich meine
last
bronze
da hab ich nicht aber da ich vorn ins
wasser wo wir wo ich bin das war es noch
okay hatte ich gehofft zu bringen alter
dann nehmen wir mal lieber macht den
wassereimer und nimmer einen mit dass
ich habe mir ist keiner rausgeflogen alt
habe brauchen unbedingt ein wassereimer
ja ja ja ich mache mir da war alles ein
bisschen illuminieren mit licht
hier würde ich muss jetzt ja hast du
gott das wasser abgebaut ja das war
unser einziges wasser in der nähe ist ja
so gut du kannst das wasser könne nicht
zwei machen oder ja aber dann hätten wir
schon mal gehabt und hätten nur noch
eine für mich finden müssen naja muss
man es so ich habe ja jetzt zu sagen
dabei
besuchte einer für mich und dann suche
ich noch mal für dich weil ich hinten
bin ich auch richtig kaskade am ablagern
aber ja also ich finde also ich bin auch
der meinung wir kommen ganz gut voran ja
nicht wirklich der festen überzeugung
aber dann vor so teams wie
taktisch verhalten wir uns ja auch
wirklich zurück also ein was einmal habe
ich schon mal so zum anmerken wir halten
uns auch gut zurück so ich habe erst mal
dreieinhalb stacks
fackeln ein halb sechs und ja dann kam
noch eine frage ich was kann ich von wem
ich guck mal hier von
schlimmer name welche superkraft würdet
ihr gerne haben
und zur parodie before you
aber ja ich würde mir gerne superkraft
wünschen dass ich einfach das meine ich
dass ich das würde ich mir allgemein
wünschen dass ich einfach permanent
diesen diesen akzent hätte dieses dann
würde sich jeder darüber lustig machen
das ja wohl die krass ist die super
kraft zu finden ist ja vollkommen ok
was bitte noch jemand antun willst du
willst du bezahlen und dann sagst und
dann klappt einfach zusammen wo lachen
was will man mehr nein ehrlich es hat ja
auch mal eure kommentare kg aber
interessieren mache übrigens die lava
quellen mit wasser zu sich ist ja über
lange hier gerade mal
den schlüssel ab
ich hoffe ich baue den fans ab wir
verlegen unsere standpunkte zu ihr rüber
in die höhlen und nicht herauskommen so
ich hab mal schönes und was der einsame
wie sand was
ist es wieder so ein spaß und einen
assist was gebaut ist wo bist du so bist
du was höchste riesenkatze wo bist du
so willst du da bist du der schlucht und
ich komme nicht ab und ich komme nicht
abholen wollte war ich
sehe ich da unten traum
sogar ist es wirklich zu geld
ist aber
weniger
wert gewinnt
das ist das okay man erstmal die nase
weg ja bist du bereit ist zu sehen
ja aber erst das passwort passwort ja
was ist denn es passt ja egal kommen ein
paar 1 punkte das noch mal an
der einsame weg sie fand
ja das sind die spuren des bauteams
liebe leute ich
kenne fackel mehr so ich habe aber noch
einiges an fackeln erstmal das und ja wo
ist meine eisen spiel da der einnahme
wupsi fand das nachwuchsteam halte man
verliert sich so kast in diesen höhen
systemen die junge wie krass einfach
diese höhle ist ob ich höre sie werden
gerade ich weiß was er kann doch keine
tipps geben
weil jeder anruf kann es noch gar nicht
so viel eisen man hat alles mitnehmen
die möglichkeit auch hier muss noch eine
falle sein in dem
alter kommen habe sich für mich
wieder zu einer was ich hier gefunden
junge aber näher die ich mir langsam
januar ok
jung
ja mein gott mein herz ist
stehengeblieben guckt ja ich sehe doch
eingang wird das reinlaufen auch immer
oh
ja ich sage euch etwas zeigen gelaufen
mein gott
was mach' langsam darunter aber ich habe
an der seite noch was größeres gefunden
was auch immer wir hier gefunden haben
ist legendär alter ist
eine riesige lover quelle ich wollte
einfach alles mit der eisenspitzen ab
leute wenn man verbindung sonst weiß ich
dass da auch ich habe gar keinen habe
ich noch platz für eisenerz habe ich
glaub ich nicht dann werfen wir doch mal
dass
wir können immer wieder ein paket die
frage machen ja genau
wie würdest du jemanden bezeichnen er
vor einem jahr sagt du wirst mal
erfolgreich auf youtube wie man ihn
bezeichnen würde ja
hellseher eine riesige lager quelle was
wir
alles läuft das gerade alles hier sollte
man logischerweise einen orientieren
können
wir müssen jetzt auf jeden fall mal
offene
einrichtung die das war
auf welche höhe
wir sollten uns auf eine richtung
einigen in die welt einstand ich finde
auch diese platz so haben etwas zu
bedeuten weil die ja überall verstreut
sind die was diese platt blöcke hier
irgendwo hier noch was krassere sanaa
sind wir also hier gibt's schon das
alles klar dann bauen wir jetzt einfach
hier kreuzen jaja ich guck mal hier
gelang hier ist nämlich nach erde wir
noch mal so ein cooles ist wenn ihr den
ganzen projekt
eine zu weiche geil alter bub sie fand
eigentlich sinnlos dieses braucht
schieben
leute
junge ist da hinten aber noch eine höhle
bei dem was ich jetzt machen was weiß
ich jetzt machen muss
zurück zur box defined zurück zudem wird
die frage gibt es dann hinein weil das
ist nicht weitermachen jaja aber wollen
ende der haben wir kein essen mehr ich
warte hier noch weiter runter hier wird
es noch eine hülle einfach mal alle
höhen hier so auskundschaften ja ich bin
ich auch dafür zwölf hier kannst hier
auf höhere elf darunter ein ein blog
thema logischerweise
logischerweise ist wieder noch
was habe ich denn hier schon wieder hier
geht es noch eine etage oder hier warst
du gerade hallo wir sind ja kein wasser
neu ist diese neuwahl der
wupsi fand war hier unter falter
da fragen wenn ihr das ich heute werden
hier ist er irgendwo eine falle wetten
ich habe es im blut ich hab' ich spüre
es in meinem
was da
ist das werde ich jetzt irgend eine
coole pflanze
blaue orchidee mitnehmen seltsame ideen
das jetzt nicht
brauchen wir nicht unbedingt
lass mal ich weiß ich habe ja noch eine
etage die leute das ist das gehört
einfach noch mal dort ja hier ist mal
wieder auf etage 11 das einfach mal
überall wasser platzieren hier auf der
ich sage ich trage er hilft herzlich
willkommen auf italien 11
wir kommen wie ich mich gerade
dann aber ich möchte mich als eher
ungünstig ich habe einfach meine
labbadia gemeine fackeln
hier schon wieder oder was ich hier von
mir schon wieder aufbaut ist ja auch ein
rätsel und eine frist am rand lang
sowie muss es doch irgendwo die ausgeben
so ich habe schon wieder clay gefunden
da muss doch was bedeuten oder brauner
clay ja noch
brauner clay oder steht da noch was
drauf die musterung gefärbt sagt lacey
uns irgendwo wo sie liegen denn in der
zeit bevor wir das nochmal gestern zwölf
minuten lassen wir noch ein paar frage
drop and wealth management bekommen
nämlich immer wieder welche rein und
zwar
hast du später forum zu ziehen wenn ja
wohin und dann single oder vergeben
also stichwort umziehen erstmal habe ich
auf jeden fall bock drauf ich will
unbedingt gerne gerne gerne nach köln
ziehen irgendwann irgendwo mal in köln
wohnen mir gefällt diese stadt war so
gut nicht wahr glaube ich erst einmal
eine wirklich so wirklich bewusst da
also was mich daran erinnern kann und da
habe ich halt rahmen besucht das war zu
dem video der ist und so nach heide
erfahrung ich habe ich einfach so hat
gefeiert und deswegen ich weiß nicht ob
er das kennt wenn man also orte besucht
und war dann einfach so eine richtig
geile erfahrung dann hat man diese orte
einfach dauerhaft positiven gedächtnis
und will dann dort immer wieder hin das
ist irgendwie
irgendwie irgendwie tun
dahin aber was ich jetzt eigentlich noch
was ich jetzt eigentlich noch will ist
zurück zum auto fanden
zum wupsi fanden hallo nachwuchs liefern
ich habe eine melone gefunden ja ja hier
sagt eine melone gefragt es macht
überhaupt keinen sinn ach ja ich habe
keine fackeln mehr das wird jetzt
irgendwie mehr verbrauchen die ja ich
habe noch einiges an fackeln hier sie
bist du bei mir zufällig ja bei deiner
nähe aber ich baue gerade cola da kannst
du ja
auch einfach hier noch ein bisschen
pharma hier muss doch irgendwo diaz gebe
leute ich hoffe nur ich hoffe einfach
nur dass wir nicht irgendwie die das
übersehen haben oder so dann lache ich
mich selbst was wir schon peinlich na
gut ich wollte ja mach jetzt der fall
jetzt einfach so an machen ein trip in
die wand ja die räder komplett runter
rewe group travel ja wir haben auch
direkt hier flint das ist gut weil er
flieht aus finden können uns fahrzeuge
machen und hat mich extrem viel gravel
anni vielleicht nicht vielleicht auch
hier sind plötzlich so viele zombies
die hat einfach eine kultur ist eine
komplette so und leute wir können für
die zukunft auf jeden fall die
versprechung machen sobald wir hier
ordentlich ausgestattet sind logo du
kannst jetzt auch schon auf irgendwas
stimmt nicht seitdem ich die melone
abgebaut hat kommt einfach immer mehr
zombies was ja hier waren gerade einfach
so viele zombie ist zudem die melone
abgebaut hast ja
wir sind einfach fitter und wieder und
wieder solche gras bei der solche welche
blöcke und jetzt wieder hier ist über
airplay wird hier wieder mehr aber ich
kann den ich kann jetzt gar nicht helfen
wir sind vielleicht runter kommen zu mir
auf höhe es ist alles gut und ich denke
mal kurz ist mit dem diamant erz
häufigsten in schichten fünf bis zwölf
das heißt da sind wir ja auf höhe elf
richtig
alles ja ich mache es mit eisenspitzen
müssen ein bisschen zeit sparen leute
mehr nebenbei so viel eisen ab so und
jetzt
an den ende er neigt sich dem ende zu 15
23 okay dann kommst du noch schätzen
hier werde ich nicht mehr schaffen hier
gar nicht wo du bist ok na gut dann
bleiben wir unten im gang locken uns aus
leute und formen geht weiter
hoffen wir schauen jetzt dass er noch
pappa diaz finden und falls nicht ist
auch egal denn schon wieder vor dem
nächsten team nach was auf den server
geht und dann gibt's
dann geht es im team
team uk wieder in die offensive damit
gefaltet dann sind sie bei der nächsten
folge wieder leute arbeiten da man sich
gefallen hat bis zum nächsten mal